racing isn't just about going fast
and with extreme e this is literally a
race for the planet
[Music]
so it's a brand new ford motorsport uh
fully electric vehicles off-road
vehicles traveling to remote parts of
the planet that don't normally see uh
motorsport or any kind of
racing of any kind
the areas that we're traveling to
they're being selected because we're
able to bring a spotlight to talk about
climate change unlike
some other international series that
travel around the globe extremely all
the vehicles and the curtain everything
is transported by boat by the saint
helena but it's also a travelling
laboratory you know it's a great
opportunity to be taking a travelling
laboratory into these areas that you
know they're being directly affected by
climate change but they're probably not
seeing what's also happening in terms of
the research and the development and
the learning side of it that makes sense
it's sort of been removed from it i
think you're pretty excited with your
science background yeah the scientists
on board will get an opportunity to
collect data from each location even
from the oceanic journey from one
location to the next and establish a bit
of a status quo of where we're at to
teach the rest of the world yeah and i
think like especially a lot of people
think electric cars are slow
um that's obviously not true this helps
people understand that you can't have an
electric car you can go fast yeah i
think that that's a great point about it
is that it's a really exciting new form
of motorsport it's not trying to
reinvent any existing form of motorsport
it's something that's never been done
before you know in these remote
locations on tracks that have never ever
been raced or you know never ever seen
an electric vehicle
motorsport from the beginning i think
works and has worked for more than 100
years by pushing the envelope of
technology with cars and whether it was
you know coming up with a nine bearing
system in this engine back in 1911 that
was more reliable through a 24-hour race
or whatever it's always pushed the
envelope of what was reliable safe
and performance and i think with
electric with ev motorsport can operate
the same way xtremia comes at a pivotal
time really in motorsport here we're
proving we're able to prove in a very
exciting way that you can take
cars and race them
expand their technology innovate on
their safety their performance their
reliability in a way that is
even a positive impact in the end on the
environment and shed light on
environmental issues that are out there
and simple things that individuals can
do to affect change on a huge scale this
opens the door for manufacturers to to
stay involved in motorsport as they have
through the decades you can see the
halls of these race cars here have all
pushed the envelope of technology for
their era now the air is ev and pushing
that envelope for ev is critical that
motorsports involved in that if we don't
demonstrate through
series like extreme e that motorsport
can be done in a responsible way and
positively impact global issues
environmental issues now then you may
not be a world where motorsport survives
that much longer so i think this is a
critical time for motorsport i think
extreme is taking the right step and
the future of motorsport depends on us
finding uh compelling ways to race these
electric cars against each other to
prove their safety and their reliability
and their performance to consumers
in order to to have motorsports survive
it's a simple way of alternatively
thinking and reusing the spaces that we
once consumed
this is greenworks i'm matthew long for
more like this follow us
on your favorite platforms